and and of course one of the big issues
of these climate pledges china
announcing details of its emission
reduction plan saudi arabia saying it's
going to
go net zero by 2060 but i mean sepi is
this really too little too late we're
talking decades in the future
thanks steven i'd say honestly it's
never too late every fraction of a
degree matters as the science tells us
and you know as a former diplomat has
put it this is not a cup final we're not
looking for someone to come out of these
talks to wave a piece of paper and say
we've solved climate change these talks
are there to generate the political
pressure for action and to a degree you
know it's working the fact that saudi
arabia the the world's largest oil
producer that spent the best part of a
few decades undermining the climate
process now feels enough political
pressure to come to the table on net
zero that's progress yeah i mean there
are some positive signs judy but even
boris johnson has said today it is very
very far from clear that we will get the
progress we need
thank you that's a valid point for boris
to make there are no insurance policies
to make sure we get exactly what we want
however the fact that the saudis who are
building nom you know a solo city
supposed to be competed by 2025 back at
the saudis who have a 600 million ton
per annum co2 carbon footprint the fact
that the saudis who would
determined absolutely to maintain the
fossil fuel era for as long as they
possibly could
are now uh pledging that they will sort
of actually get to a point by 2030 where
they cut their methane output by 30
percent where they they draw out a plan
so that by 2060 they are net zero
all of these are great starting points
for us to continue to talk to the saudis
and just as a minor aside
while we've watched global politicians
dance around the issue of net zero i
think that
prince charles's position of being able
to convince an alternative monarchy in
the middle east with its challenges to
actually change its course
from backing its national uh uh industry
champion aramco to turning around and
saying that they will look at
alternative diversification their
economy i think these are wins i think
this is to be celebrated okay but i mean
what always strikes me with all of this
step is that you you you both pointed
out the other good steps forward that
are being made but there is always a
there's a lot of rhetoric involved here
and the action is always much slower in
coming and when even the the one billion
pound pledge that was meant to be you
know
beginning to be met last year has now
been pushed back to 2023
the action never follows the rhetoric as
quickly as we want it to does it
certainly not as quickly as the science
says it should and that's a fact you
know developed countries have had 12
years to come up with this 100 billion
per year and you know whilst uh they
suggest that they'll be able to meet it
from 2023
and average uh you know 100 billion over
the next five years it's yet to see
whether that will be enough for
developing countries
i mean it's interesting in all of this
separate
chatty with all the the the problems
that arise when we look at the
international commitments through all of
this
uh the secretary general um
said that you know the the needed
changes are economically affordable and
technically possible there is no time to
lose now
when we hear those sort of words to say
it is technically possible and
economically viable
that leaves us with very little excuse
we need to put much more pressure on
somehow don't we
100
i mean to even narrow it more firmly the
u.n second general called this a code
red year after the ipcc's wg um
one report came out just a couple of
weeks a couple of months ago we know for
a fact that there is a capacity in
countries across the oecd to make very
rapid changes to decarbonize very
quickly what we're seeing is that there
are obvious roadblocks to change that
happen at national government level
which is why this particular year where
we have cop26 coming to britain in this
particular year where local uh city
level uh uh initiatives are starting
this is a year where real change can be
made and this is a year where if we do
pay attention even after cop at cop27 if
we have to we can carry on putting
pressure on governments at local and
activist levels in a way to remind them
of their their obligations and their
duty of care they have was their
citizens
you